When people talk about big data, they nearly
always talk about data science, and data
scientists, as well. Now, just as the definition
of big data is still debated, the same is true
for the definition of data science. To some
people, the term’s just a fancier way of saying
statistics and statisticians. On the other hand,
other people argue that data science is a distinct
field. It has different training, techniques,
tools and goals than statistics typically has.
Now, that’s what we’re going to
talk about in this presentation.
The first thing that we want to do, is
we want to look at what’s called the
data science venn diagram. This is a chart
that was created by Drew Conway in 2010,
and what he’s arguing here is that data science
involves a combination of three different skills.
The first is statistics. That’s on the
top right. The second, on the bottom,
is domain knowledge that you actually
know, for instance, about management or
advertising. And the one on the top left is
coding, or being able to program computers.
He’s arguing that, to get data science, a person
needs to be able to do all three of these.
So, we’re going to talk about each of these facets
one at a time and in combination with each other.
The first component of data science is statistics,
which shouldn’t be surprising because we’re
talking about data science. The trick here is
that a lot of things that go into statistics and
mathematics can be really counterintuitive, and
if you don’t have the specific formal training,
you can make some really big mistakes.
The second element of data science is
domain knowledge, and the idea here is that
a researcher should know about the topic
area that they’re working in, so if you’re
working in, say for instance, marketing,
you need to understand how marketing works, and
that makes it so you can have more insight and
better direct your analyses and your procedures
to match the questions that you might have.
For instance, there’s a wonderful blog post by
Svetlana Sicular of Gartner Inc, where she writes,
“Organizations already have people who know their
own data better than mystical data scientists.
This is a key. The internal people already
gained experience and ability to model,
research, and analyze. Learning Hadoop, a common
software or framework for dealing with big data,
is easier than learning a company’s business.” And
that really underscores the importance
of domain knowledge in data science.
The third element of Drew Conway’s
data science diagram is coding,
and this refers to computer programming ability.
Now, it doesn’t need to be complicated. You don’t
have to have a PhD in computer science. A little
bit of Python programming can go a very long way.
It’s because this allows for the creative
exploration and manipulation of data sets,
and especially when you consider the
variety of data that’s part of big data.
The ability to combine data that comes in
different formats can be a really important thing,
and that often requires some coding
ability. It also helps to develop
algorithmic thinking, or thinking in linear
steps-by-steps to get through a problem.
Next, we’ll talk about combinations
of two of these elements at a time.
The first one is statistics and
domain knowledge without coding.
This is what Conway calls traditional research,
and this is where a researcher works within their
field of expertise, uses common tools
for working with familiar data formats.
It’s extremely productive, and nearly all
existing research has been conducted this way.
The second combination is statistics and
coding without substantive expertise.
This is what Conway refers to as machine learning,
and now, that’s not to be confused with data
mining. Machine learning is where an algorithm or
a program updates itself and evolves to perform a
specific analytical task. The most familiar
example of this is spam filters in email,
in which the user or a whole large group of
users identify messages as spam or not spam,
and the formula that the program uses
to determine whether something is spam
updates with each new piece of information to
have increased accuracy the more you use it.
The third combination here is domain
knowledge and coding without statistics.
Now, Conway labels this a danger zone,
with the idea being that you have enough
knowledge to be dangerous. While there are
problems with this, I’ll mention two things.
First, Conway himself mentions that it seems
very unlikely that a person could develop both
programming expertise and substantive knowledge
without also learning some math and statistics,
so he says it would be a sparsely populated
category, and I believe that’s true. On the other
hand, there’s some really important data science
contributions that come out of this combination,
including, for instance, what are called word
counts, which we’ll talk about later. It’s simple
stuff. These are procedures that do not require
sophisticated statistics. You’re just counting
how often things occur, and you can get important
insights out of that, so I wouldn’t write this
one off completely. I would say, though, that
like Conway, it’s not likely that a person could
develop expertise in both coding and their domain
without getting the math and statistics as well.
And finally, of course, there’s all
three of these things, statistics,
domain knowledge, and coding, at once, and that
is the most common definition of data science.